all together let's see if you guys know
the words ladies and gentlemen this is
Hans Kim
[Music]
what's up
[Applause]
just got back from Korea
if you thought we all like the same
before the pandemic
try telling us apart with masks on
I was living with the wrong family for
three days
come back to America and what do I see
black Little Mermaid
one of the races that are known for
being one of the worst at swimming
this is gonna get people killed
look at me mommy I'm a mermaid Laquisha
no
[Laughter]
[Applause]
grab onto this chicken leg
what's next a movie about an Asian
NASCAR driver
teradiga Knights
thank you Hans Kim ladies and gentlemen
wow
about a minute 40 seconds 26 seconds of
it straight up Applause Just saying the
word sup
an incredible performance Hans how you
feel I feel amazing
I always do and uh thank you so much for
everything
I'd imagine a lot of you traveled a long
distance to see something that you've
seen on the internet so many times right
in front of you just the most honest
autistic but like but not quite
[__] weird ass [__] Hans yeah
a joke Guru how you been feeling lately
how was your trip to South Korea for
real it was amazing I uh you know didn't
download any porn they'd block porn
websites over in Korea I was just
jerking off the tweets and memes ah
I uh was with my family
yeah
they really block porn yeah you can't
get a VPN I can yes you did didn't you I
did it
I'm not buying it you're a little too
internet Savvy to get trapped
take the man out of the van you can't
always take the van out of the man
which VPN did you use was it expressvpn
because you could get it right now using
the promo code kill Tony
[Applause]
yes
Hans what else has been going on in life
anything else you want to tell these
amazing fans out here I have been uh
doing great I recently went to Korea and
uh my family was kind of being a [__]
to me they uh they have this new baby
it's kind of taking all the shine oh no
oh no who's the who's the family over
there my sister and her Chinese
boyfriend oh
[Music]
how controversial is that
is that of Chinese people they are a
Chinese boyfriend for your sister it's
almost as bad as a white dude really
[Applause]
but Japanese would be worse right yeah
but not as bad as a black dude yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's pretty Universal
yeah
it's the one thing the whole world
agrees on
not your mom Tony how much cocaine have
you been doing I've been almost doing
zero cocaine really yeah almost zero is
not zero it's a very interesting way to
put it we're guarantee my mom would have
a different answer
almost zero
[Music]
Hans a lot of people have been talking
about your cocaine addiction uh people
have been talking about since headlining
all the time I mean let's face it you've
done in two years on this show what very
few people have been able to do you took
this opportunity and you completely
started doing long sets on the road you
got better at doing long sets on the
road and now you're headlining all the
time anytime you want and selling out
adding more shows things like that so a
thing that uh
dude you killed in arenas yeah you've
killed an arena you killed in Madison
Square Garden thank you Joe
um I like to take credit but
I know the right people
well that brings me to my next point
because I was thinking how can we start
this show extra special in a way that's
gonna Boggle people's [__] minds
forever
and you've done so much I don't know if
you need this every single week but I
know you love doing it right yes so I
figured I'd put you in a little bit of
an awkward position here I think we
should do something that we've never
ever imagined doing in the history of
the show and that is a battle for
regular ship
oh [__] so
Hans put that mic in the mic stand go
sit next to Michael Gonzalez's drums
uh what What's about to happen is
something that uh I I just cannot wait
to see how this goes uh you're about to
see a golden ticket winner perform for
the chance to become a full-time regular
on the show
and since you animals in this room you 3
000 people sold this place out in one
hour
I'm going to let you decide who moves on
to be the new keltoni regular is that
cool
ladies and gentlemen doing a minute
a brand new stand-up comedy that we've
never seen before this young man is one
of the first ever golden ticket winners
he won it on the road five years ago in
Houston Texas
he moved here to Austin just a couple
months ago to [__] live his dreams
the kid is a monster it makes a noise
for kill Tony golden ticket winner
Enrique Chacon
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ER I used to be a fifth grade art
teacher bro
which made sense because I look like a
[__] lesbian
and yeah man I was teaching at this very
rich school called River Oaks Elementary
bro but I had one of my students they
didn't [__] respect me because this
allowance was higher than my salary
I asked little Hunter how much he made a
week this [__] said nine hundred
dollars bruh
and I was like man [__] these paint
brushes it's time to start selling some
Adderall Fitness [__]
so they fired me bro whatever dog
so I decided to go teach at a Mexican
school that was dope bro love taking my
kids to lunch right it made me feel like
an adult it also got high as [__]
possible bro
so I will walk my kids to lunch and I
felt like a mama Doug taking her baby
Douglas in a single foul line real cute
right
but when I was high I felt like in
coyote sparkling back to get children
into the US
single foul line stay quiet and it
started and don't come back I still get
paid [__] rest [__] these kids
thank you a minute from Enrique Chacon
the Young Buck
the young Force coming to try to
Dethrone resident regular Hans Kim how
do you feel about the position that I
put you in tonight I feel like I got
that dog in me baby
[Applause]
is it hot dogs you're talking about
you're making Hans hungry [__] it
Whatever It Takes how many glitzy
gobblers it takes bro
whose dick do I have to suck around here
dude it's actually mine it's my deck
easy answer
so here we are you have the chance to
replace Hans Kim whereas Hans would be
in a position to get to perform still
pretty much any time he wants is a
legend of the show future you know kill
Tony Hall of Famer uh gets to plug his
dates if he wants to come on and do a
spot but someone's got to write and
perform a brand new minute every single
week Hans why don't you come up here
stand next to me baby
you've watched Hans grow up in front of
your Berry eyes this is a tough decision
you guys have you know almost nothing
about Enrique Young Bucks still yet to
hit the cocaine addiction and bottom and
the Mountaintop sharike is holding the
microphone that's a significant
advantage
[Laughter]
so should we solve this once and for all
how many of you guys
let's make some noise how many of you
think Hans Kim should retain his throne
as a regular
damn that's loud two years and they
ain't sick of him yet
that's gonna be tough to beat
how many of you have Enrique Chacon
winning let's go
Hans Kim is the [__] ladies and
gentlemen
hasta luego
Hans will get to decide when Hans
retires from the show
Hans grab the microphone from Enrique
how about one more time for Enrique
Chacon everybody there he goes
follow me
I'll Follow You Enrique you have a small
joke book
[Music]
Hans how do you feel man these
these people love you they picked you
over a brand new human they've been
watching you for two years and they want
more of you how does that make you feel
it feels amazing to see Mexican people
get demoted again
huh
it is incredible I didn't even realize
that was a battle between an Asian and a
Mexican
I should have had the winner get a bunch
of rice you guys both like rice a lot
so Hans
you still retain we'll see you on Monday
you feel good yes yes thank you so much
Tony Make some noise for Hans Kim
everything thank you
[Applause]
and that was on Kim